parti de chenonceau mais originaire de
la ville rose toulouse c'est touristes
sont du pain béni pour saint georges sur
cher comme disait rabelais on peut être
drôle tout en étant sérieux ne paie mon
ami effectivement et à saint georges sur
cher on n'est pas loin d'autriche aaron
entre la frontière entre le 37 et le 41
et ce alors chercheur à une époque était
connue parce qu'il y avait un calvaire
calvaire qui a été grandement modifié
avec le temps il était sur les collines
est effectivement ici on vivait
également de la culture de la vigne avec
le phylloxéra s'il ya eu quelques soucis
et depuis basse à georges sur cher est
devenu un passage rôle essentiel puisque
vous êtes entre le zoo de beauval et le
château de chenonceau c'est georges sur
cher se trouve sur la route des châteaux
de la loire et des vignobles prestigieux
pas étonnant que la petite commune de
moins de 3000 habitants
bénéficient de ses retombées c'est
l'effet d'aubaine vous n'êtes pas loin
de loches avec une citadelle royale qui
est magnifique avec deux sites on y
aller hier c'était beau loches on est
d'accord vous avez également le zoo de
beauval et saint-aignan-sur-cher avec
une magnifique collégiale à visiter et
vous avez également notamment le château
de chenonceau qui à côté ensuite je ne
pourrais pas citer tous les sites
touristiques parce que la touraine c'est
plus de 300 grands sites touristiques et
une centaine de châteaux invités alors
venez nombreux on vous attend de passage
à saint georges sur cher
ces touristes vont par exemple découvrir
en face de la mairie l'église du même
nom 12e siècle est inscrite en 1926 à
l'inventaire des monuments historiques
en vrai nous sommes de passage parce que
nous avons fait une croisière sur une
mini croisière sur le cher et c'est à
pommiers les alors château de chenonceau
donc
entre les deux sets à rien ce village
pour nous supporter alors tu déjeuner
toutes les tables sont réservées cet été
les places étaient rares beaucoup de
touristes les marchés ont les gens ils
ont envie de sortir un petit peu sortir
un peu du confinement des repas en
famille que du bonheur un dernier regard
sur saint georges sur cher à partir de
son port la saison estivale se retire